[Music]
whether you're a believer or a skeptic
you have to admit that ghost adventures
is pretty darn entertaining yet there's
more to this series than just
investigating creepy abandoned areas
with extensive paranormal histories so
let's investigate the untold truths
behind the guise of ghost adventures
zack spooky collectible
whether you love or hate zack the ghost
bro bacon style he puts his money where
his paranormal loving mouth is whether
cameras are rolling or not
in august 2015 bacon's plunked down 32
thousand dollars for a van that belonged
to dr jack kevorkian who notoriously
assisted with the suicides of 130
confirmed patients bacon says he doesn't
plan on using the vehicle for ghost
adventures but he does intend on
investigating the van he told the new
york daily news i want to have it to
show recognition to these people and the
energy they had at the time of their
death i can't wait to get it and see
what i feel off of it it called out to
me that's one heck of a collectible bro
the macabre extends to their real lives
reality can be a lot scarier than any
haunted house paranormal investigators
mark and debbie constantino were
featured on ghost adventures and now may
be featured posthumously on a true crime
series krnv tv reports that the couple
had a long dark history of domestic
violence that history came to a tragic
head in september 2015 when mark killed
debbie as well as himself after an
extensive swat team lockdown
too scary even for them
biggins purchased a gary indiana home in
2014 after reports that the family
living within it were terrorized by
demons these reports were backed up by
claims from child protective services
who also witnessed the creepy activity
problem was the house was actually too
scary even for bacons
tmz reports that while filming a
documentary in the home bacons felt dark
energy and claimed the demons were the
real deal bacons tried exercising the
house but said his attempts failed
believing the house was actually a
portal to hell bacon's paid to have the
house demolished in 2016 and even had
the rubble stored in a sealed facility
so no paranormal energy could escape
from it and affect anyone nearby phew
thanks for watching subscribe to our
youtube channel to see more videos like
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to tell us what ghost adventures
facts surprised you the most